μου και τους συνερτςμούκοντά ου καθεμέραπουε για τον υπουργών ικον ομικών υπανόται παρθεκι τρειις φορές
όχιήσημαελίδου πω εσφοεπίσημα όχι ανεπίσημα και αστι ευόμενοι πολλές φορες λέω εντάξει σε εδώ ήταν
φτάν δεν το καταλαβαίνουν αυτό πως είναι δυνατών να μην το καταλαβαίνουν είτε οι βουλευταίς
μας είτε ιγωνείσει τις υνδικαλιστές αλλά μετά αμέσως παίρνω περισσότερη και μεγαλύτερη δύναμη και λέω
όχι θα θα το οργανώσω καλύτερα θα το δουλέψω εγώμέσα μο με τους συνεργάτεσμου και
θα πάω πολύ τεκμηριωμένα και νιώθω έτσι και πιο δυνατίωσον περνά ο καιρός γιατί στην
αρχή ενιώ θα ότι επειδή δεν είμαι πολιτικός μπορείνα να μην πίσω τελικά είναι αρκετόν
να ξέρεις το θέμασου είναι αρκετόν να είσαι ηλικρινίς πιστεύω και να πείζ ναι αν
έχω λάθως έχω λάθος ανδεν έχω όμως θα το πάρω στο τέλο κιο θα πει
και θα παλέψω γι αυτό σε αυτό το υπουργείο θεωρίστεπετυχημένα αποψημο και τ πάμε στην
αρχή των λόγο σχετικόν αυτό ναι θα τομεκέ πορέλεσμααν τω δικέύρινο όπως λένε οι κακές
γλώσς γίνει ανασχηματισμός και σας πάρει ο νίκος χριστοδουλής και σας πι κυρία μιχαελίδου θα
σα αλλάξω υπουργεο αναμέμπο σπίτι μου υπουργείο πιον υπουργείν θα ήθελε μια θυνα μιχαλ νομίζω
όπως κατάληλότερι με μόνο γι αυτόν το υπουργείο δεν μπορώ να ξέρω αν μπορώ να
λειτουργήσω σε έναν άλλο φαντάζουμε και σε αλλον υπουργειν μπορώ να ακολουθήσω τις ίδιες αρχές
και αξίες αλλά θα είναι πολύ διαφορετικά αλλά θέλω να τον ίσω δεν το φοβάμαι
εγώ των αννασχημάτισμ δηλαδή είναι δικαίωμα του προέδρου αποκλειστικό δικαιώμαντου αν για κάποιο λόγο όλοι
μας μπορεί να θεωρούμε στε ότι μαστε εμπετχημένοι αλλά ο πρόεδρος δεν το πιστεύει θα
το σεβαστώ πλήρως τον ευχαριστώ ίδι που μου έδωσε να αυτή την ευκαιρία να κάμω
πράγματα για το εκπαιδευτικό σύστεμα και τό